foreign
let's go to Daniel in Cincinnati what's
up Daniel
good afternoon sir how are you
outstanding my brother how are you
oh not too bad a little nervous I don't
be nervous it's all good man what's up
oh watch one of um apologize in advance
when I get nervous or anxious I Stumble
over my words and sometimes my train of
thought deviate so hey uh Tomball I
apologize in advance have you ever
listened to this show
I have and it makes me feel a little
better but I Stumble over everything
with me on the show I Stumble over
everything not because I'm anxious I
just can't speak properly uh but hey
thank you for for being brave and
calling in any way even though this is a
terrifying proposition for you I'm
grateful for you so what's up man
okay well
's other life has happened since I made
the
the uh
to your booth crew um the original
question was how I can handle anxiety
around
uh unlike whenever I see news or things
happening in the world or
just I mean kind of referencing how what
you've struggled with when you just
think like what's gonna happen when it
all falls apart when at all it's the fan
how am I going to provide for my family
how am I going to provide for like work
what if I lose work and the nerd work
the nerd word for that is
catastrophizing
there you go okay all right so that was
your original that was originally why
you called in
that yeah but I'm in the time in between
I've been trying to I'm wondering if it
is just possibly a symptom of like a
bigger anxiety or just something more
because
I get hit with that catastrophizing
at different times and then it just
throws me for days or sometimes a day
but I kind of have to like bury my head
and all have to like listen to
audiobooks or podcasts or I kind of have
to like
I don't know if I'm making myself forget
it or I just wind myself down from the
initial build up so can I can I use can
I use your situation as a teaching
moment for everybody listening because I
think it can be a great gift to folks
yes by all means I'm going to walk
through with you a series of questions I
think your your impulse is absolutely
correct
okay
um barring some sort of
um brain lesions and things which are
super super super rare I think your
impulse is very correct
um so I'm gonna go through a series of
questions that I normally ask folks who
are struggling with anxiety these are
the questions I ask myself okay
okay um
none of these questions are judgment
questions okay so
um
the only way to get to like some truth
is you just to just say it as quick as
you can and as honest as you can cool
same team
yep all right so
overall weight and health how are we
doing
good good
you exercise regularly you sleep okay
um you're not
you're not super overweight
no not overweight I'm pretty active in
my job I do construction carpentry
excellent says sleeping's as good as we
can as good as I can do I've got some
younger kids that okay from time to time
but I say overall sleep well yeah all
right how much how much money do you owe
other people how much debt do you carry
uh 20. like if you just had a grand or
so okay that's credit cards how about
your house
just uh
just add a little bit of personal loan
to a family member
how much in your house
uh
throughout 20 or just reload low 20s
around 20. so you'll have your house
paid off with 20 grand
yes wow we are we are running towards
that as as fast as we are able all right
in-laws
do they run your life or they are you
pretty connected
oh real very connected very yeah okay
very connected very close what about
your folks
uh same very connected very close uh
would not be where I am in life without
either set of in-laws or parents
excellent friends do you have a group of
guys that you do life with you hang out
with outside of work
working working towards that that's been
something
last month or so you guys
meeting with two individual two older
gentlemen uh from church that I respect
and then I have a couple of friends that
um I would get together whenever we can
so no
in your dream in your dream world yes
but in reality no I've got some guys
that I work with on job sites and then I
come home to a wife and some young kids
yes okay all right cool
um what about things the nerd word here
is anxiogenic so tell me about your how
much coffee Red Bull how much caffeine
do you in you take
uh uh of a couple of tumblers through
the morning or the Working Day and then
past that just some just tea and water
in the evenings okay all right
um tell me about your marriage how y'all
doing
so not great so tell me about it
I would lean toward great there's just
we're trying to work through raising
kids uh we had an idea of what how we
would parent but that's the that's the
Newlywed idea of it but other than that
I think that's the biggest stressor is
just learning how to raise kids and live
live life okay
[Music]
um
how many kids do you have
three with a planned one in this fall
okay and what's what are their ages
uh five three and almost two oh good
grief okay next time you talk to
somebody about anxiety lead with that
okay
that you have a three wild animals that
live inside your house
um okay
um tell me about
childhood trauma any stuff lingering any
things that were tough growing up
um
before listen to your show I would have
said no trauma but
um I'm starting to wonder if I need to
come learning to redefine that word
um
growing up I mean things were great
money was tight at times but we my
parents were very diligent and gave us a
great a great life growing up
um
my parents came to came to Faith uh when
I was young and so my early years were
kind of I have memories of
them kind of working out how to live
life and how to do that in a
um
in a faith base we started going to
church and I think there was some
kind of the pendulum swinging of
learning through that
um that may be there may be a little bit
there but again I'm just kind of
starting to starting to look at that
through the lens of
what could that have Are you a
this is going to sound like a loaded
question and just just be honest with me
okay
are you someone who has almost a
supernatural ability to
compartmentalize things that disappoint
you or hurt your feelings or hurt you in
order of making sure everybody else
keeps their reputation and then
everything looks good
try again
I'm not sure let's put it that way okay
all right
um some people
not a ton of them but some people had
incredibly smooth lives
just had no bricks in the backpack man
and some of them then moved up to be
adults and they ended up with a pretty
great life
and they're a they have a pretty great
marriage and they got the chaos of three
young kids and that's life
um but they kept plugging along and they
paid their house off while they were
still really young so they didn't even
have that stress anymore that happened
more common and again I don't want to
create problems where they don't exist
okay so this could be you and that is
man I'm high-fiving you
and
there is an intense pressure on millions
and millions of people
to be peacekeepers and image bearers
and
there is a deep-seated it feels like a
deep betrayal to talk bad about somebody
or to tell the truth about a situation
or to be honest about just how hard or
negative or how how much you're
struggling with something
and it's the great vessel Vandercook
says your body's keeping the score
and so it could be you know we just
adjusted with the pendulum as as we were
kids
and it could have been
screaming knock down drag out fights or
things that we used to do all of a
sudden we couldn't and parents looked at
you and said you want to burn in hell
forever right so
there's one way of telling that story
then there's another way of telling that
story and it may have just been nah man
my parents decided to start going to
church and they decided that they were
going to start living this way and there
was a natural clunkiness to figuring out
how that works but that's that's normal
I don't want to put stories in your in
your head that don't work your language
sounds very careful to me
yes okay and sometimes very very careful
language very calculated language is
language is a way of speaking that
somebody has had to adapt and develop to
keep themselves safe
and if that I would agree with that if
that's you
that's anxiety
that is a body underneath that like
there will not be any ripples in this
water
and that is a body underneath that water
struggling for air
see what I'm saying
yeah so you can go back over those
things I just talked through
and say okay where am I struggling to
say I'm really mad
or I'm really scared real scared
or this isn't what I had in mind or I
miss my wife
or quite honestly my parents provided
for us and they were tough to be around
they weren't abusive I don't want to use
that word they were just really hard to
be around and I don't feel safe going to
them for stuff and I'm pretty lonely you
see what I'm saying
there's a uh the first step in in
healing from an anxious life is owning
reality choosing reality this is the
truth about my life
okay and so we don't have to do that on
this call but I think that's an
important place to start uh my friend
will godera he's a um a restaurant here
one of the best on the planet in New
York
I love what he tells his weight staff
he says you can only fill other people's
picture
when yours is full
okay and so what he's telling his staff
is you guys got to go do the hard work
of filling your picture up so that you
can show up for these customers who come
to our restaurant I want to take that
analogy and and
completely reverse it for anxiety
you have an anxious life
if you've got a bunch of stuff going on
or a bunch of unspoken things that you
haven't fully connected
your body is going to be at capacity
that picture is going to be completely
full
and then you throw on top of it we're
going to war with China we're going to
war with Russia world war three is
happening we're gonna have food and
climate shortages we're gonna all stuff
your body's anywhere else for that stuff
to go
you see what I'm saying
yeah and so then you have to get into a
cycle of avoidance I'm just gonna not
watch this stuff
until the water stops trickling into
your already overfilled pitcher
and so the question I want to ask you is
where do you have
what you're describing to me is someone
who's created a very anxious life that
then when what I call normal stressors
there will always be wars and rumors of
wars when those things show up they
become overwhelming they override the
system
so going back and choosing reality where
is a place
that you're you've filled this sucker up
probably a lot of places because
as you've been laying it out it's just
things just keep coming to mind okay oh
all right oh oh I mean like I do
um I've explained yeah just say just say
it just say it just try to tell it to my
wife like I bottle things up yes and
then it either has to come out or it
boils over and but I just yeah there's
just I just find it really hard to open
up and talk to people about anything and
then like you said I'm being careful
with my words to keep everything happy
and hunky-dory and that makes it
difficult to have hard conversations and
also it also makes it very hard to be
married to
and it makes it very hard and I'm not
shaming you I'm just I I want you to see
the dance that happens
when somebody walks up and feels like
they're talking to somebody's Twitter
account
it's hard to plug into that with true
connection
and when somebody's married to somebody
who is just basically a screensaver with
how wonderful things are
they feel crazy
because things aren't wonderful
and then they withdraw a little bit
and then the person behind the screen
savers body is screaming whoa whoa
connect connect but it can't get through
the screensaver
and you see how it just creates a dance
and then that person gets a little bit
closer then that other person pulls
further away and now we're in a kind of
a mess
you see what I'm saying
yeah
and so here's the the beautiful thing
that you're dealing with is there's not
any wild overt Madness
the challenging part for you is
I was making a salary that my granddad
couldn't have wrapped his head around
and so was my wife and we were married
and we were paying off six figures of
debt and we had a two-year-old little
boy after years of infertility and I
went mad
I went mad with work expectations I went
mad with dreams of what things were
gonna be like one day I went mad with I
was sharing a bed with somebody that I
know loved me but I was incredibly alone
I was paying off all this debt but my
body kept asking for what what are we
doing
like what okay so we pay off our house
then what right you see what I'm saying
and it just their alarms the anxiety
alarms kept getting louder and louder
and louder and louder
and my dad was a cop and a minister you
talk about good at wallpaper language I
was one of the best
you hear what I'm do you hear you hear
it so I do here's the here's what I I
won't do a couple of things
and it's gonna sound like a like a weird
twist I'm gonna send you
all the ones I have all of the the
couples ones the dating ones and the kid
ones the questions for humans
no man thank you you don't have to do
that thank you well it's I love you and
I'm I'm grateful for your bravery
I want you to start using these cards to
have no
um
uh just just
no expectation conversations with people
that you love
I'm gonna send you the guys nights out
and you can just have some buddies over
and y'all can do whatever watch the game
watch football watch fights whatever it
is y'all do I don't know you can go
build cabinets or I don't know you sound
like like a guy knows how to do stuff
um or y'all can sit around have chips
and queso and
play Texas Hold'em and use these cards
but I want you to start practicing human
connection okay
then I want you to take a piece of paper
and I want you to write down things that
you do not fee where you do not places
where you do not feel safe
and be honest and then be very clear
about what I can control and what I
cannot control you cannot control
whether China's sins missiles to Russia
and escalates this thing into World War
III you can
you can't control whether China invades
Taiwan you can't
you can't control whether Biden does
whatever and then whoever gets elected
after him gets does whatever you can't
control any of those things
and there's something powerful about
letting your brain know yeah these are
happening and we can't do anything about
it and literally after a season of
practice your brain will begin to create
a gap between oh we got to do something
and oh that's not our problem to solve
because we can't and then it won't sound
the alarm so much anymore
see what I'm saying
yeah so does the piece I guess that's
kind of one of the reasons I was calling
was just how do I find peace and not not
the stress of it just is does the time
of
after those alarms quiet does this the
piece of knowing like oh what's I mean
what's I can't control it and the
outcome may not be may not be great but
I can't control it is that where the
beginning of the piece comes from the
beginning of the piece is this when your
body starts to feel anxious you ask
yourself body what are you trying to
protect me from oh Russia we can't do
anything about that one
and then you let that like literally
feel it run through your body get
anything about it and so
continuing just to scroll on the news
sides tell me how it's all coming down
we're all gonna die and blah I can't I
can't I'm just gonna turn that off
because that's not helpful that's just
gearing me up and gearing me up and
gearing me up and gearing me up
now if an invasion happens
I'm gonna stay glued to the radio
because I want to know where the bombs
are falling
that's not our world right now
once I know that inflation's high and I
go to the grocery store I can see those
prices they're expensive
I'm done with the inflation conversation
because the only thing I can control is
my budget how much money I'm bringing
into my house and the choices me and my
wife make about what we buy and don't
buy that's what I can control
not how much bacon is not how much
cereal is or whatever see what I'm
saying so the piece comes from
disconnecting from I've got to be in
charge and control everything
and instead it's about
I've got to get connected
I've got to take care of my body
I've got to be very intentional about
where I'm not safe
and I've got to focus on the things I
can control versus the things I can't
control
and I want you to be really really
graceful with Daniel because Daniel's a
good good guy he's a great husband he's
a good dad
he's a great provider he's doing good
things for his community
and he's learning to live in a new body
a body that's a father of three going on
four a body who's married to a woman who
he loves desperately and they've never
been married with three kids almost four
before
it's all new we're all learning
I'm gonna be really graceful with our
bodies I'm also going to send you a copy
of own your past change your future I
want you to go through that book and
check out some of the stories you may be
hanging on to that you've learned over
the years to talk really eloquently
about
but that may be spinning your body up
Amazon your copy of redefining anxiety
just a quick read to read through it and
um
uh just know this I'm really grateful
for your call
you're looking at a guy who's been there
and on the other side of it there is
peace there's peace
start practicing and start building a
non-anxious life